Allah Allah bütün eski dediğimiz şey
Ciddi bir problem Öncelikle Hani bu
konuşmayı ben bundan diyelim yaklaşık 10
sene önce yapmış olsaydım Burada Hepiniz
de şey konuşulur bu için değişti
gerçekten var mı Hani böyle havalar
ısındı mı bir şeyler oluyor mu ama 10
senedir başımıza o kadar büyük belalar
geliyor ki buraya Çıktığım zaman hani
herhangi birinize İklim Değişikliği var
değil mi kanıtlamak gerekmiyor artık
Hani belki İçinizde Amerikan başkanı
falan olanlarınız olmuş olsaydı onlara
kanıtla mamız gerekiyor olabilirdi Ama
geri kalanlar Biliyorlar yani bu hani
2017'de biliyorsunuz arabaların üstü
böyle bırak bırak olduğu dolu yağdı
hepsi 17 dakika sürdü korkunç bir şey de
onların tümü dolayısıyla da hani
problemin olduğunu biliyor
yok Yalnız daha önce oldu böyle birşey
mesela önemli bir sorunuz olmuş ya böyle
uzun Çağlar oluyor hava ısınıyor soeuyoe
ısınıyor soğuyor ve işte 20 bin sene
sıcak dönem oluyor sonra 80 bin sene
gayet soğuk bir dönemden geçiyor sonra
tekrar ısınıyor bu periyodik periyodik
olmasın arkasındaki sebep de güneş dünya
bir de Jüpiter üçünün etkileşmesi nden
uzun çağları geliyor periyodik Ondan
sonra daha da geriye gittiğimiz zaman
milyonlarca yıl önce de var bu
dinozorlar yaşadığı zamanda sıcaklık
bundan çok çok daha yüksek yaklaşık bir
10-12 derece falan daha yüksek
karbondioksit seviyesi de bugünkünün
ve en katı falan oluyor mu oluyor Hayat
gayet mutlu bir şekilde gelişmiş durumda
var ama buradaki ana problem şu
değişiklikler bir gününden ertesi günü
olmuyor yani buzul çağından bugüne
geçmek öyle hani Haydi yarın karar
verdik sıcak döneme geçiyoruz olmuyor
yüzlerce Hatta Binlerce yıl sürebiliyor
buzul çağına gittiğimiz zaman bu milyon
yıl mertebesinde sürüyor neredeyse şimdi
Dolayısıyla bugüne özel kılan şey bütün
bu değişikliklerin bir gününden ertesi
güne çok hızlı olması tabi büyük
milyonlarca yılda baktığımızda şu
geçtiğimiz 150 seneye bir gününden
ertesi güne diyebiliyoruz niye oluyor
peki bu iş markasında bir tane sebep var
o da TP bir kısmı burada olan ama hani
gerisinde sayacak olursak 7.8 milyar
insan yani burada herhangi birini İşte
sen bu işten suçlusun falan diye öyle
parmakla gösterecek durumda değiliz
çünkü hepimiz bu işin bir ucundan
tutuyoruz ya
A101 kimin değişmesine Çünkü biz kömür
petrol doğalgaz tüketiyoruz bunları
yaptığımız zaman atmosfere karbondioksit
çıkıyor çıkan karbondioksiti bütün
yaptığımız Bela'nın yüzde yetmiş aşağıya
kır hani şunu da yapmıyor muyuz Evet
yapıyoruz ama yüzde üç bunu da yapmıyor
muyuz Evet yapıyoruz yüzdeki ama ana
dert kömür petrol doğalgaz
bu ve esasında bundan çok önce 1896'da
bir tane Biz ikçi kimyacı ortada çalış o
zamanlar çok belli değil bu fizik kimya
konuları hangisinde hangisi oldu soğan
tarihimiz diye bir adam var Man tarihi
yüz bir araştırma yapmış diyor ki eğer
biz atmosferdeki karbondioksit miktarını
iki katına çıkartacak olursak dünya altı
derece dağıtılır 1896
Evet şimdi aramıyorsun yaşadığı zamanda
karbondioksit miktarı atmosfer Didi mini
minnacık oynadı mini minnacık bunu hani
yüz değil ölçemiyorum milyonda ile
ölçüyoruz karbondioksiti o zamanlar
281/2 katına çıktığında 560 olduğunda
Dünyamız sıcaklığı altı derece artacak
Böyle bir öngörüsü var birini bugüne
geldik bugün Diyoruz ki dünyanın
sıcaklığı Evet altı derece artar Eğer
282 katına çıkartacak olursak yani 560
olursa
Evet tamam Bu da iyi Şu anda kaçtayız
13 115'lik ilk ölçmeye başladığımızda
1958 yılında aletler o günden bugüne
günde defalarca ölçüyorlar karbondioksit
miktarını bugün çıktığı yer 415. üstü
12180 daire iniyorsun zamanında 415 yi
bulduk 560 olduğunda dünyanın sıcaklığı
altı derece artacak bir de şöyle bir şey
söyleyeyim geçen Ben Ankara'da bir
okulda konuşuyorum orada buna benzer bir
şey söyledim bakın dedim Siz işte ve 12
sene içerisinde bu problemi çözmeyecek
olursak
çok kötü olacak durum 4. sınıflar
dinliyormuş beni o gece uyumamış lar
Çünkü mm otuzun yılbaşında dünya yok
olacak diye alıyorlarmış şimdi tabi
problem böyle bir gününden ertesi güne
bir anda olan bir şey değil gene Yavaş
yavaş olan şeyler bunlar ama olacak
çünkü bilim insanları karar vermeye
çalışıyorlar Hani bunda bir derece mi
kötü iki derece mi kötü Çünkü are you
zamanından bu zamanı yaklaşık 1.2 derece
arttı dünyanın ortalama sıcaklığı ve
devamlı da artmaya devam edecek Çünkü
karbondioksit artıyor dedim ki 415 Bugün
her sene üç artıyordu
e560 ı bulmamız yani altı derece yüksek
olması 2050 bulmayacak büyük ihtimalle
şimdi bu da çok ciddi bir felaket
senaryosu oluyor ama hani dediğim gibi
bugünkü için korkutmak için korkutmak
olduğunda arkaya böyle kötü resimler
falan koyuyorum böyle orman yangınları
Avustralya yanıyor Koalalar falan
bugünkü işimiz o değil bugünkü işimiz
biraz daha Bunun sorumlusu kim onu
araştırmak soruşturmada baktığımızda
devletler Çok ciddi bir sorumlusu bu işi
Çünkü devletler bu oyunun kurallarını
belirliyorlar Yani neyi alacağız nasıl
satacağız nerede biriktireceğim nerede
toplayacağız nasıl kullanacağız bu
kuralları belirleyen devletler onlar
korkunç sorumlu bu işte
Bu soruda şirketler var yani bizim bu
yediğimiz içtiğimiz giydiğimiz
kullandığımız gezdiğimiz bozduğumuz her
şeyi üreten şirketler var Onlar da çok
büyük sorumlu
yok Yalnız farkındaysanız bu
sorumluluğun arkasında
bir kişi daha var o da esasında biziz
bu çünkü hani devlet dediğiniz şey
biliyorsunuz
o bizden başka bir şey değil her ne
kadar böyle Devleti yüce bir şey gibi
görme derdimiz olsa da bu memlekette
devlet biz Bizden başka bir devlet yok
Dolayısıyla Biz oy verdiğimiz zaman o
insanlar bizim yerimize ülke
yönetiyorlar onun içinde bugün Eğer bir
sistem içerisinde yaşıyorsak bunun
arkasında gidemez ve bizim oy vermemiz
Biz oy verdiğiniz müddetçe bu sistemi
destekliyoruz bu sistemi destekliyoruz
danla kastım kömür petrol doğalgaz
yakıyoruz bunların belirli bir üretim
sistemleri var dağıtım sistemleri var
Bunun hepsini biz belirliyoruz
değiştirecek olan da gene hepinizsiniz
hepimizin
bu ama hani bunda bir grupta var Ona
Sonra geleceğim Çünkü şöyle bir problem
var bilim insanları biraraya
geldiklerinde şey diyorlar yani Tamam
gidiyoruz kötü bir yere de
o neresi kötüsü Hani bu çocuklara
dediğim gibi mm otuzun yılbaşında Dünya
bitiyor mu yiyecek
bu çünkü biz esasında teferruatı dünya
açısından bakıldığı Biz gideriz dünya
gene de devam eder bizden sonra ona bir
soru yok ama hani Olsa iyi olur Bu
dünyanın içerisinde fena değiliz
birlikte gibi duruyor sanki dünya ile O
zaman diyoruz ki Hani beraber ne
yapabiliriz bilim insanları diyor ki iki
dereceyi açmayalım bu sunmada Çünkü iki
dereceye açacak olursak
Selam bugün kontrolde olan çok mekanizma
kontrolden çıkacak Yani mesela şimdi
dünyanın Ortalama bir sıcaklığı var
belirli bir şekilde yaşıyoruz bunu
olmasın arkasındaki sebep de mesela
Kuzey buz denizi dediğimiz gibi buz
Deniz yani buzla kaplı beyaz bir yer
beyaz biliyorsunuz genel ışığı
yansıtıyor ondan dolayı davran çok fazla
ısınmasına neden oluyor ama diyelim Bu
buz Eridi o zaman güneş okyanusa gelecek
okyanuslar koyu renkli olduğu için ısıyı
biraz daha fazla yemeyecek sıcaklığı
daha fazla artacak o bölgenin sıcaklığı
daha fazla arttığında bu sefer
grönland'ın üstündeki buzullar erimeye
başlayacak aynı şekilde Güney Yarım
Kürede aynısı olduğunu antartika'daki
buzulla vermeye başlayacak sonumuzu
verirse ne oluyor biliyor musunuz
Ama ben bunu başka yerde söylediğimde
kızıyorlar taksimoda oluyor 80 metre
Deniz seviyesindeki yükselme hafifçe
korkun ama aklınızda olsun Bakın bu size
çok Baba tavsiye bugün böyle denizden
Bayağı uzak yerlerde yüksekliğe bir
bakın Hani cep telefonlarında var Onu
uygulaması ne kadar olduğunu gösteren
yaklaşık 80 metre civarında bir yerden
tarla almaya çalışır Hani şeyler oluyor
ya ya Eskiden burası Dutluk Muş rahmetli
babaannem demiş ki de deme vakitte
şuradan yer alalım Dedem de demişti
orada kurtlar oluyor olan ve bu
hikayeler hepimizde vardır İşte ileride
torunlarınız diyecek ki size ya iyi ki
bak almışlar şuradan ne biçim turistik
arazi oldu Buralar öyle bir dünyada
yaşıyor olacağız ve hiç hoş bir dünya
olmayacak Bu Dolayısıyla biz bu uçuruma
doğru gidiyoruz Şu anda Kendi aramızda
konuştuğumuz şey ya nedir
Bu arada konuştu şey şu şimdi arabada
gidiyoruz karşımızda uçurum var uçurma
doğru geliyoruz şimdi ben freni mi
basayım frene çok mu basayım az mı
bastım yoksa El frenini çekim El frenini
çekerken frenemy basayım uçuşunu da biz
böyle hani olan hızla gidiyoruz uçuruma
doğru ama biz bunları tartışıyoruz El
frenini Fren mi direksiyon mu falan ne
yapmamız gerekiyor biliyor musunuz
ve kapıyı açması atmamız lazım
mı böyle bir sistemde yaşıyoruz maalesef
işte en önemli problemimiz bu Biz o
sistemin şarkılarını işleterek O sistemi
bir çözüm bulmaya çalışıyoruz Bu sırada
da böyle çok hayatımızı bozmayalım gene
aynı araba Olsun Gene yine aynı el freni
olsun gaz olsun Fren olsun debriyaj
olsun falan derdindeyiz ama öyle
olmayacak çünkü uçurum şunu da görüyoruz
uçurumun ve uçurma doludizgin gitmek
teyiz Eğer sağ kalacaksak Cümbür Cemaat
El freniyle direksiyonda falan
olmuyormuş Kapıyı açıp biz atmayacağız
araba gitsin
bu çünkü başımıza ne geldiyse arabanın
yüzünden geldi esasında şimdi Einstein
videosu çok dizi konuşuyoruz ve bir laf
söylemiş diyor ki başımızda gelen
problemleri çözmek için o problemleri
başımıza getiren sistemleri kullanamayız
Paşa tam böyle dememiştir Almanca
söylüyor Çünkü aynısı ama anladınız ne
demek istediğimi Yani şu anda başımıza
bu belayı getiren şey o arabanın kendisi
esasında kullandığımız sistem ve o
sistemin içerisinde onunla biraz oyna
Buna biraz oynay Lala biz bir yere
gidemeyiz yeni bir sistem gerekiyor
bugün Twitter'da bu iklim konusunda
düşünce üreten çok önemli insanlardan
bir tanesi Namık Lan bir şey yazmış
diyor ki şimdiden bir arkadaş paylaşmış
Lütfen bunu yaygınlaştırılır şimdi
dekilerin sloganı ymış bu konuda iklim
değişikliği konusunda eylem yapan
bu Dogan diyor ki biz Ne o liberalizmin
ya da kapitalizmin çocukları ya da
torunları olabiliriz ama insanın
yaşaması için hepimizin yeni bir
dünyanın anne-babası olmak zorundayız
tercümesini hazırlayıp oldu Özür dilerim
ama ana laf bu yani burada benim için
artık birazcık geç olabilirmiş çünkü
hani yaşlı köpeğe yenii oyunlar öğretmek
birazcık zor oluyor ama burada bir sürü
genç var Biliyorum bazıları da ve bu
gençler dünyayı kurtaracak olanlar Çünkü
biz o arabayı ürettik o araba şu anda
uçuruma doğru gidiyor hep beraber
arabayla gidecek olursak
bu durum kötü Onun için benim yapmaya
çalıştığım şey mesela bu gençlerle
birarada durmak Ve bu çok önemli bir şey
çünkü ondan şu anda savaşmaya başladılar
hani ne kadar duyuyorsunuz biliyorsunuz
bilmiyorum ama bu çocuklar artık anne
babalarına gidip bu ışık niye burada
yanıyor hesabı sormaya başlıyorlar
Eskiden büyüklerimiz bize sorardı
mutfaktan geldiğimde mi Işıl söndürmedim
de falan Şimdi tam tersi olmaya başlıyor
Anne baba içeri geliyor çocuklar
mutfağına şimdiye yanıyor diye laf
ediyorlar Öyle bir zamana gelmeye
başladı Ben de çocukları elimden
geldiğince fiş bekliyorum
ve bütün gittiğim okullarda diyorum ki
gidin anne babanıza hesap sorun
gerçekten tatile o kadar uzak bir yere
gitmemize gerek var mı uçağa bilir
gerçekten şunu almamıza gerek var mı
Bununla mutluyduk buranın ışığı niye
yanıyor bu hem 25 derece şu anda bu
kadar tutmamıza gerek var mı Ya da bu
kadar soğutma mıza gerek var mı Onlar da
yasak sormaya başladılar ve hesap
sormaya da devam edecekler iyi bir şey
bu çünkü onlar yeni sistemi kuracak
olanlar onlar Kapıyı açıp aşağı atlayıp
kurtaracak olanlar bizi yoksa biz kendi
aynı da kaldığımızda
ama Bayağı kötü aşağıya doğru gidiyoruz
Onun için elimizden geldiğince çocuklara
yardım edelim yani Lütfen karşınıza
çıkıp niye kapatmadın buranın ışığını
diyen küçükler olursa
bu pardon Doğru haklısın deyip
kapatmakta fayda var teşekkür ediyorum